9h30 devant les portes fermées du lycée
quelques minutes avant les résultats
l'atmosphère est un peu crispé mais a
juste à dire je suis très stressée je
veux rien dire parce que ça me porter la
poisse
enfin c'est le grand moment il m'a tant
chez ba jadis par mon métier c'est bien
je vais aller déposer ma faim dans mon
école et après je faire la fête mais il
y a ceux qui n'ont pas réussi du premier
coup il faudra passer les épreuves de
rattrapage comme il vous manque de
points 34 points oui ou non
et puis il y a ceux qui ne l'ont pas du
tout en province les résultats ont été
donnés dès lundi cet après midi en ile
de france les oraux commence pour ceux
qui n'ont pas tout à fait la moyenne
vendredi tout sera terminé
les lycéens seront six étudiants ou
encore élèves pour un an
16 heures
les résultats viennent d'être affichées
c'est l'apogée du suspense
alors que certains en sont encore à
chercher leurs noms sur les listes
d'autres laissé éclater leur joie
ça fait extrêmement du bien de la voir
ouf
tu va le fêter alors là pas de problème
d soir on fait tout ça c'est bon pour
vous oh oui avec la mention mention quoi
assez bien oui assez bien et vous
attendiez à cette mention tout entier
attendus pour moi moi je pensais pas
mais tout le monde a cru que ouais bah
oui qu'est ce que ça donne pour toi eh
ben je rattrape âge et tu espères que ça
va marcher je suppose ouais j'espère tu
vas bosser beaucoup pour le rattrapage
bah je vais bosser de marque huawei
verra bien à ton avis qu'est-ce qui n'a
pas marché
la physique début j'ai pleuré tu sais ce
que tu vas faire après ouais joue à la
fac d'anglais sont attendant je fais
restera se souvenir celui de la
recherche
inquiète de son nom sur une liste
18h17 ouverture des portes et ruée vers
le dénouement ambiance émotions
[Applaudissements]
heureuse je me rassure je j'étais
capable de la voir c'est l'aboutissement
d'un travail signale heureux heureux
[Musique]